[Musique]
l'inauguration d'une usine en Inde un
événement riche en couleur et en musique
une fête pour consacrer le partenariat
entre l'entreprise canadienne
d'imperméabilisation du béton sipex et
c'est partenaires locaux
l'usine qui emploie 130 travailleurs
n'est pas encore pleinement opérationnel
que le PDG canadien entrevoit déjà une
expansion en Inde
les perspectives sont alléchantes dans
le pays le plus peuplé de la planète les
moins de 25 ans représentent 40% de la
population
l'un des parieurs en pleine
transformation le secteur de la
construction par exemple vit une
expansion sans précédent
le Canada veut sa part du gâteau dans
les secteurs de la construction de
l'agriculture et des technologies vertes
entre autres l'un des un des piliers de
la stratégie du Canada pour l'Indo
Pacifique afin de diversifier ses
investissements en Asie et dépendre
moins de la Chine les échanges
commerciaux dépassent les 100 milliards
de dollars annuellement 14e partenaire
économique du Canada laine pourrait
faire son entrée dans le top 10 dans
quelques années
les gouvernements canadiens et indiens
ont repris l'an dernier les négociations
dans le but de conclure un accord
commercial global les deux parties
espèrent arriver à une entente d'ici
quelques années
hapuné près de Mumbai c'est l'entreprise
québécoise et pique machinerie et son
partenaire local qui profitent de la
croissance de l'économie indienne les
commandes pour l'équipement lourds et
les systèmes de manutention
c'est que de nombreuses entreprises
indiennes investissent maintenant dans
l'automatisation de leur
productions canadiens des piques
machineries étaient d'ailleurs de
passage en Inde ces dernières semaines
afin de trouver des usines potentielles
à acquérir ils veulent doubler leurs
capacité de production dans les
prochains mois attirés par le potentiel
du marché indien le Canada met l'accent
sur l'accroissement des liens
économiques entre les deux pays pour se
faire le gouvernement de Justin Trudeau
ferme les yeux pour le moment sur
l'érosion accélérée de la démocratie et
des libertés individuelles en Inde il
s'est Philippe Leblanc Radio-Canada
punais en Inde